hey everyone welcome to Simon dev in
this project I created a flappy bird a I
basically I'm going to revisit my flappy
bird implementation from a while back
but juice it up with some neural
networks and evolutionary algorithms so
this AI learns to play flappy bird by
evolving a neural network this has been
done a few times before so it's not
totally new but what I'm gonna do is
build this entire thing from scratch
instead of just using some pre-built
library our AI learns to play flappy
bird using a custom neural network like
I said this is all from scratch so the
neural network the genetic algorithm all
completely from scratch I can totally
just go and grab tensorflow
or neato j/s but you learn by doing
right I'm kinda interested in fiddling a
bit more with machine learning and yeah
I've used tensor flow before but this
time I'm just straight-up implementing a
densely connected and your own network
myself and you'll be surprised at how
simple it is and how a few lines of code
it is like always the code is all
available on github so take a look if
you're interested the link is in the
description below I've tried to clean up
the code as much as possible well we'll
go over today is mostly how I created a
flappy bird AI will start by taking a
look at my old flappy bird JavaScript
implementation so if you remember back
from one of my first projects I wrote
flappy bird in JavaScript
we'll do a quick overview on neural
networks and genetic algorithms and then
how this a I learned to play flappy bird
by evolving in your own network my old
flappy bird JavaScript implementation
the first project I ever did in
JavaScript that was more than a couple
random lines there's a few things that
we need to have support it's poor so
we're gonna go over the code a little
bit and take a look first off if we want
our AI learning to play flappy bird we
need the game to support multiple birds
at once which is super easy
we'll just instead of hard-coding a
single bird instance in the main game
we'll turn that into a list of birds and
then the game ends when they all hit
it's not just one of them the other
thing we need to do is derive from the
bird class to create a sort of flappy
bird neural implementation which doesn't
need any keyboard input instead it has a
neural network and each frame it uses
that to decide whether or not to flap
then we have a couple additional classes
first here's the new population which
handles the evolution of these neural
networks this is a simple process
mirroring evolution we pretty much just
throw a bunch of random birds of the
game and when the game is over we sort
of decide who was the fittest in real
life that's who ever managed to survive
and have the most kids but in this what
we want to do is say the longer you last
in the game the fitter you are then it's
a simple matter of sorting from best to
worst and randomly choosing two parents
at a time to make new children but we'll
wait the randomness towards the best
ones and finally here's the neural
network code there's not much to it
because at least the forward operation
on neural networks is really simple
now neural networks are capable of some
super magical level AI but at their
heart they're super simple things here's
a really basic neural network that
consists of two inputs and one output
the lines between the circles represent
the weights which are just random weight
values and the way the output is
calculated is pretty much by doing a
matrix vector multiplication followed by
a vector addition what you do is
multiply the weight matrix by the input
vector add what's called the bias vector
and then run the result through what's
called an activation function which is a
function that sort of massagers the
values into a specific range or not
depending on which activation function
you use so here's a quick example now
this isn't a neural network tutorial I'm
just going to give you a really brief
overview and you can look into it more
deeply later if you want all this is is
matrix times the input vector plus the
bias vector then run it through the
activation function with our simple set
up here this amounts to a bunch of
multiplies and then adds on the GPU
these are commonly referred to as Mads
or multiply accumulates and you can read
the Wikipedia entry if you want so back
in the code
these ten lines or so - the comments are
pretty much all the work that needs to
be done for a densely connected neural
network and in fact taking a step back
and looking at the overall class
ignoring the serialization code this
entire thing is like what 25 lines
there's not much work going on here
before we start training these things
here's the last thing to call out we're
not using NEET here or neuro evolution
of augmenting topologies implementing
that would take a bit longer and I don't
really feel like it but also it gives us
an interesting thing to examine one of
the things that NEET does is that
involves both the weights of the neural
network and the topology that is the
structure of the neural network we're
not going to do that we'll just involve
the ways but we'll choose three
different structures simple medium and
complex and we'll see who wins so in the
green corner we'll have the complex
neural network which consists of two
hidden layers each with nine neurons
then here on the blue team we'll have
not quite as complex neural network you
can see I reduce the number of hidden
layers that's pretty much all I did
finally in the red corner we have these
kind of simple neural nets one hidden
layer was only five neurons each of
these Nets will get a few simple inputs
will include the bird's current velocity
the distance to the next pipe the
distance to the pipes top and bottom and
I'll also try feeding in the pipe after
that to see if it helps let's kick this
off and we'll sit back as the AI learns
to play flappy bird and we'll see who
wins this right off the bat everyone
kind of sucks right now a few birds
randomly get through but that's out of
hundreds none of them have figured out
much in the way of how to handle the
openings between the pipes so I'm going
to fast forward a bit because this took
a long time for them to actually learn
to do anything the blue team here is
looking really promising and they just
tit a pipe okay not bad but they have to
start over
again the blue team is starting to kill
it they've got a really high score going
on but the red team is also looking
really good here okay so blue team just
blew their lead but the red team is
going strong and Green Team so far has
shown no promise whatsoever if we fast
forward a bit more
red team has pretty much figured out
flappy bird they're just they're just
destroying it so let's declare them the
winner now I'm going to fast forward
even more because it took a while for
blue team to figure things out but they
eventually did around the one hour and
thirty minutes mark taking them at least
an hour longer to get to the point where
it might just run forever Green Team was
unfortunately pretty hopeless
even with another hour and they were
still fumbling around getting scores of
a few dozen and then randomly hitting a
pipe the problem is that their networks
are so massively complex compared to the
other two the number of parameters that
need to be evolved in the complex green
bird is four times as many as in a
relatively simple red bird and twice as
many as in the blue bird so I guess the
moral of the story is less is more I
have no idea whether or not the Green
Team would have eventually mastered
flappy bird I assume that given enough
time it would have but I didn't let it
keep running forever around the three
hour mark at was enough they were still
fumbling around and hadn't improved
substantially so that's it our a I
learned to play flappy bird using some
simple neural networks and genetic
algorithms you can experiment with the
code if you want maybe try to figure out
the smallest network that stills plays
perfectly or try reducing the inputs I
can see you only feeding in the first
pipe for example or removing other
inputs it's all a pretty hand wavy
whatever works I hope this was easy
enough to follow and if you enjoyed this
video and want to see more like it give
it a like and hit that subscribe button
in the corner also let me know what
you'd like to see in the future and
leave a comment below until next time
cheers everyone